february is black history month and a
las vegas family has created a really
cool way to celebrate with virtual
reading nights yeah alex the project is
called
we see you there are 25 books from black
or brown authors
and every day they'll be read by locals
and highlight themes like civil rights
activism and escapism the books are
aimed for children
and some include questions at the end to
try and engage the minds of parents
and young readers this project is
extremely intentional in the way that
our we wanted our the kids that were
viewing these videos
to also turn on the youtube video and to
see people who look like them
reading who have had an array of careers
well there's a new clip every monday
through friday it is free to watch and
we have a link to this
at 8newsnow.com alex and 8 news now is
highlighting inspiring african-americans
here in the las vegas valley
again as part of our black history month
special you can watch it on sunday
february 14th
at 6 30. it'll be great